[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash hi babies
let's see what's going on here on my
website I'm gonna look this up here
should already looked at already but I
didn't I'm live on my app right now and
it's all good so if you wanna you can
download my app and then you can see me
alive for the first 10 or so minutes on
that on the on the app for each episode
and it's buzzy and my headphones and you
know what yeah
so one fighter had it good and then
[ __ ] it all up and it's buzzing in my
headphones we're figuring it out but
we're still going dude because we don't
stop dude we don't stop this [ __ ]
podcast we don't stop it we've never
stopped it we've stopped at once but we
stopped at once and we had to read or
redo it because I thought that it was so
bad for the first 12 minutes but that
was only one time and that was like
[ __ ] episode 30 or some [ __ ] I will
be in Santa Barbara Riverside California
San Diego
Foxwoods Bethlehem Pennsylvania
Rochester New York Detroit Michigan and
and I'm shooting my special in
Minneapolis my babies that's how we're
doing it there's no more buzzing in the
headphones one fire fixed it he fixed it
yeah you fixed it I'm gonna be in Tampa
too and Melbourne Florida so get your
tickets at Krista Leo calm so get your
tickets at Krista Leo calm www Chris
D'Elia calm you go over the tour to the
video and you go check out where he's
County Conan - the place near you he
also you check out his favorite lady's
favorite videos Chris ludic house and
also miscellaneous there's a
miscellaneous section that Chris Lee
himself is absolutely never clicked and
then there's a podcast section area you
know listen to the podcast here so and
you can go pick up emerge but here we
our crassula calm no www so yeah and I
don't know you know what did I do this
week sir I was in Santa sanim said
senator barbara meant to say New Mexico
was in New Mexico I had one day off the
day offs in Albuquerque are so terrible
do you know why yes you do because
they're boring
I'd rather work than do nothing in
Albuquerque that's how [ __ ] up it is
Brown I'd rather work I'd rather be a
hundred and ten degrees and sweating and
wearing my flight suit and all the
[ __ ] ammo and guns then literally
have a day off Brown because it's about
rang my cookie is boring dude whatever
you know did shows so I got home flew
back bought a flight then asked them if
I could go back because that's how I do
it dude I'm into the secret man I'm into
that thing that thing the secret you
visualize it you see it and it happens
did I visualize a lot of [ __ ] ice
cream in my belly last night apparently
because they so much ice cream and
Pringles yeah he's gonna get cancer dude
a Pringles and popcorn the whole time I
was doing that I was thinking I'm doing
this instead of the ice cream and then
lo and behold couldn't stop himself so I
went to the fridge and I got the [ __ ]
chocolate brownie ice cream from Ben &
Jerry's Brown it's Ben and Jerry fat
probably have no idea but they gotta be
so ate the Ben and Jerry's ate the
Pringles dude remember that thing once
you pop you can't stop
or what was the chip that was like bet
you can't eat just one was that Pringles
or jury dose bet you can't eat just one
whatever it was there was a chip company
that did that in the 90s and that was
smartest [ __ ] because he can't dude
imagine eatin one chip what are you a
[ __ ]
so you find out if somebody's a
communist or not or a [ __ ] robot
Lai's dude that's what it was even as a
kid when I heard the name Lay's I
thought about [ __ ] I got problems
yeah dude
Lay's potato chips once you pop you
can't stop 1983 commercials in 1983 were
so [ __ ] up
but yeah so you'd eat one and then you'd
be like where's the other looking on my
app someone's saying I'm a relatively
new baby and always listen to this on
the speaker so for a while I thought you
were saying a cash app fastest way to
send money to France ahead what am I
saying
Oh to friends yeah I have a way of
speaking that's different did you turn
me up in the headphones or something he
changed it and it made it way [ __ ]
worse don't [ __ ] change it yes dude I
love when when [ __ ] I love when [ __ ]
gets [ __ ] up dude it was fine hi hein
it was fine dude just like I said so I'm
wearing all white dude because it's
Sunday it's my Sunday [ __ ] and it's
Sunday dude and I have on [ __ ] what
do you call them slides and socks
because I'm [ __ ] Persian
that's why dude did you know that so
Persians do dude
they were socks and [ __ ] slides
because they gotta be like I don't
really give a [ __ ] but also the slides I
have her very cool so but also I'm
relaxing so yeah uh it's all good dude
I'm just chilling and and this is this
is how it is so I was in a [ __ ]
Albuquerque it was a day a day off it
was boring as [ __ ] chilled worked out
then shot a scene the next day and then
it got wrapped early and then flew the
[ __ ] home I was on the plane didn't even
get him first class just got the last
seat that I could get and [ __ ]
so the same flight attendant that I did
and I'm starting to see all these
[ __ ] people over and over again and
she was like back again and I said yep
she said in Albuquerque I said yeah man
I'm here for a bit I'll be seeing you a
lot she was a tall drink of water man if
you're a tall flight attendant you
probably gonna get scoliosis you know
what I'm talking about because you got a
[ __ ] hunched over
that's why flight attendants are so you
know even the guys you never seen a tall
guy flight attendant they're always real
real short and gay why is it a gay thing
to be in the air the higher you get it's
a gauge it's weird how it's like a gay
job for a guy well why is that how come
there's some jobs that are just like
like if you're a guy and you do it it's
usually a gay thing I don't know what it
is about being 30,000 feet in the air
that makes you want to [ __ ] dudes maybe
it's maybe that's maybe it's that's the
thing maybe maybe you're not gay and
then you were like just so in the air a
lot that you're just like oh man the
airs thin gotta suck a dick um man what
if [ __ ] for real Chris Cuomo just
said that on CNN what I just said he'd
be done he'd be done that's why being a
comedian is the [ __ ] yes Chris Cuomo if
Chris Roma was like so we're here with
the guy you know talking about liberal
stuff and he's he's a he's a flight
attendant is that right yeah so how come
that's a gay job and you suck dicks if
you're a flight attendant cancel dude
but I'm a comedian and you can't get me
yes um so yes so a [ __ ] I'm chillin
and then I got home and I did a show and
it did another show and it did another
show and I did another show I did four
shows and I stacked them my babies I
stacked them like [ __ ] I know not
that what I do it I mean what what that
what that girl Riley Reid would do
because member she put the thing out
that's it's that complicity forever the
episode I'm not a perv I'm not saying I
stack of my pushes like I stack [ __ ]
you stack em [ __ ] like the porn star
who tweeted the thing about that
complicities and if you haven't seen it
so sue me all right that's your ass
all right ha also everyone stop diem and
me the [ __ ] stupid meme where
everyone says my hands are tied now and
it's got a girl with tied on her hands
that is simply not funny to me
ever okay so um there's a bunch of [ __ ]
right now
that's just not funny online the chad
and brad thing see ya
i'll do a beauty queen wave on that bye
bye dude let me drive by him five miles
an hour i'm in a goddamn parade waving
at that brad and chad thing it's gone
dude beautiful this [ __ ] with a glove to
my [ __ ] elbow bye bye I don't want to
[ __ ] there's [ __ ] that that they do
that all of a sudden catches on like
wildfire that is immediately not funny
as it is funny boom boom that's it stop
stop with the [ __ ] with the jump on [ __ ]
you know the Brad and Chad thing it's
just so lame where would they see white
guys and they're just like alright Brad
and Chad woo I saw I think I'm Barstow
Sports on the Instagram um wherever they
did the [ __ ] where the guys were in a
boat and these guys and these [ __ ]
five white guys were doing like silly
dancing to these girls and their [ __ ]
girls there were so many girls in the
boat and there was a guy that was like
alright Brad and Chad like making fun of
the guys on the boat with all the girls
man hey dude you're the [ __ ] dork
doing the unoriginal joke from a boat
away wishing you were on that [ __ ]
boat with all the girls
seems like Brad and Chad's winning [ __ ]
that dude uh I'd rather be the [ __ ]
Brad and Chad than the guy calling the
guy Brad and Chad it's so lame dude
people just jump on this [ __ ] I got a
[ __ ] white glove down to my elbow and
I'm in the back of a [ __ ] 1960s
convertible and I'm doing a beauty
dude I'm a beauty queen
I'm the Rose Bowl Queen on you man I I
don't like when people just all of a
sudden jump to the thing nope I see it
you know what else is like that white
claw yay see ya I don't give a [ __ ] it
was funny for [ __ ] three minutes and
now everyone's like white Club that's
the drink that dude alright it's the new
Zima or whatever people are jumping on
board with this club soda [ __ ] man
it's crazy how companies can push that
[ __ ] and then it's just so on
I've been driving drinking [ __ ] club
soda for nine years my babies
not that I like it I first know why
because it tastes like absolutely
nothing with bubbles yeah it does and
why did I start drinking it because I
stopped drinking diet coke and why did I
stop drinking diet coke because I was
drinking too much of it yes was it ever
good no coz diet soda it [ __ ] sucks
donkey balls and I started drinking it
because I didn't want to be fat though
is that right yes and why because I was
written five cokes a day yes because
coke nan diet is good yeah but what
happened why did I stop drinking coke
because I didn't want to get fat and
cancer no because one time I lifted up
my shirt as a joke for my mom and she
said Chrissy gained weight and I said no
I didn't and she said yeah I have a
scale go look at it and I jumped on it
and I was 20 pounds heavier yeah
and did I almost faint yeah and that it
stopped drinking coke then yeah and then
I started drinking diet coke drink white
claw by mistake thought it was [ __ ]
club soda there's too many Club sodas
out there I don't drink dude you guys
know that I don't drink I didn't ever
drink and I Drake about [ __ ] three or
four sips of white claw and I was like
man this is [ __ ] weird drink dude I
don't drink alcohol and I was just like
this is a weird drink and I kept
drinking it and I was like this is stuff
alcohol in it and I looked and it
does who's the guy drinking [ __ ]
alcohol
who's the guy who's the guy drinking
white Clyde Damien knowing who's the guy
drinking man backstreet boys made some
hits huh
oh whatever it's the same one fire came
through with the NSYNC I should know you
know some [ __ ] ultimate friends with
the Backstreet Boys dude I could call
that [ __ ] AJ right now dude literally
I won't cuz he's got his own life but I
could call Nick Carter now dude
Nick Carter invited me to his show and I
said yeah I'll come just text me and he
[ __ ] didn't but we have each other's
number he was gonna play a [ __ ] small
get-together I like the London hotel and
I was gonna go if he texted me and he
didn't and it's fine because I you know
kind of that meant that I had plans and
then I had to [ __ ] couldn't back out
of it so I didn't text him because it
was on him and it's fine dude but we're
buds and that's Hollywood man that's
[ __ ] straight-up Hollywood that's how
we do it in Hollywood for real yeah yeah
I'll call you all great and you know
immediately that person's not gonna call
it's how it's gotta be though there's
too many [ __ ] plans you know if you
go to the mid maybe you go in the middle
if you go to East if you go to like they
start making plans and you keep those
[ __ ] once you're not around
water you stick to the script you know
say like Denver Denver probably they're
so high but like Utah Oh bro they got
they got an itinerary
you go there and they're like these are
the plans and like go check the ones you
want they're like we're holding you to
it if not then you know I don't really
know what I'm saying bro what is this
that's gross that that's there there's a
little [ __ ] shot glass of milk here
cool yes that's been there and been
curdling yes dude
[ __ ] yes dude hmm it's been there in
curdling for weeks [ __ ] yes dude all
right it was today but whatever dude
it's I bet but we left [ __ ] here for a
long time before okay yeah so was I
saying so people are jumping on that
[ __ ] soda water thing I've been
drinking it for [ __ ] nine years which
isn't long enough by the way I liked it
you know the people who are like I like
the band before you did
I'm trying to do that with with club
soda but I can't do it because it's only
been nine years you got my my dad bro my
dad's been drinking Lacroix he added in
his bottle not Lacroix but like club
soda my dad would rent club soda and as
a kid I'd be like why do you drink that
that doesn't huh why did drink that it
doesn't doesn't taste like anything and
he's like well you know I liked it
because I don't like soda and I'd be
like why didn't you just strike water
then and he'll be like well because I
like the bubbles and they say yeah we
owe it out yeah we owe Dow so I don't
know what else to say man but by the way
is that is the air conditioning [ __ ]
it is a toddler no it's okay okay
[Music]
there's a thing in a [ __ ] uh suite
and I saw where is it I thought I had it
here dude this is funny man seaside
towns high-tech anti-sex toilets will
spray users with water not gonna stop
them what if you have that's your kink
oh dude you're gonna get hay getting
sprayed is part of sex now but there's
this I don't know loose in Porthcawl mmm
I mean loose in Porthcawl South Wales
all made up weary from loose
oh and Porthcawl yeah South Wales head
made it all out wet it will feature
weights
censors and sound alarms to stop
antisocial use dude this is so weird to
me that this is where we're at this is
on the Guardian the Welsh seaside town
of Porthcawl is planning to install
anti-sex public toilets that would spray
occupants with water and sounded an
alarm all right so look first of all how
much [ __ ] is going on in these in the
in these toilets
okay like is it just is it just all day
because then okay if it's not all day
then just who really cares you know
consensual sex in bathrooms okay violent
movement sensors would automatically
open the doors Oh a kinky I mean dude
they want to see it violent movement
sensors would automatically open the
doors and sound high pitch alarms with
fine water jets soaking the interior the
sexiest thing ever so all of a sudden
you're [ __ ] and then it's gonna go
and it's gonna go all right the [ __ ]
doors are gonna open and then you're
gonna get [ __ ] doused with water and
you're gonna be wet [ __ ] ah sexy yeah
the government has a king I mean dude
South Wales what is that Welsh oh so
sexy they're not gonna stop them dude
I've run into that [ __ ] thing I want
to [ __ ] and you're gonna have people
watch and spray me with water okay [ __ ]
that dude when the dick goes boom and
the doors open and I get [ __ ] doused
with water I'm going [ __ ] uh I'm
amping it up dude I'm amping it up my
babies for real you think I won't [ __ ]
that dude a hundred percent while this
[ __ ] goes down boy and I'm in there with
a [ __ ] dude [ __ ] the dude and just
I don't give a [ __ ] dude
[Music]
are you kidding me oh no here comes the
water Oh what's going on over there I'm
what's coming on over there oh here we
go
blast all over [ __ ] whatever their
names are all over [ __ ] Christian
that's the only guy I know that's well
she's Christian Bale for real dude are
you kidding me bro that's it
why can't I move the thing can't move it
great yes can't move it can't move the
[ __ ] soundboard thing why is it
happening can't move the soundboard
thing it's up there and I can't move it
technology dude send it over to [ __ ]
want fire babies yeah dude that's
ridiculous why would you want to be I
mean oh how much [ __ ] is going on in
in in Welsh land in Welland how much
[ __ ] is going on over there in bathrooms
here's the other thing deal here's the
other thing to not house the other thing
to spending so much money on this alarms
doused with water weight sensors bro you
know how much a weight sensor is I swear
to god they're a hundred grand I have
that on full authority that weight
sensors are a hundred grand look at this
Porthcawl Town Council is spending oh
here we go 170 euro thousand dollars or
whatever the [ __ ] it is that little e
with the curvy thing at the top you know
what I mean what is that
that's probably around the same emember
American in Griffin Park
according to Wells online the planning
documents detail a range of security
features to deter rough sleeping
you mean [ __ ] rough sleeping dude
that said they didn't want to [ __ ]
admit it oh so they don't want to admit
that they're pervy yes hello we are
Welsh your planning documents to detail
a range of security features to deter
rough sleeping I swear to God including
an audible warning combined with the
lights and heating being switched off
with lights and heating being switched
off I wanted to [ __ ] put him freezing
all toilets would be fitted all toilets
would be fitted with a full
high-pressure floor and wall washer
which could be operated after every use
Jesus Christ you know so much this is
how you know nothing's wrong and when
[ __ ] where is Welsh [ __ ] Wales that's
how you know nothing's wrong in Wales in
America we're like everyone's dying and
getting shot and in Wales they're like I
let's put weight sensors in our [ __ ]
public restrooms because we don't want
people to be having too good of a time
I'm moving to Wales dude and [ __ ] in
where is this Porthcawl in Griffin Park
dude I'm going there Brook [ __ ] that
that's a red light what if you went in
there and it was all like like red lit
and [ __ ] and Leslie's like so nice they
had paintings on the wall that were like
you know this is the kind of the [ __ ]
they're trying to trap you dude they
want you to [ __ ] but also want money out
of it all toilets will be fitted with a
full high-pressure floor and wall
washers that could be operated after
every use or after a certain number of
users per day each night the toilets
would close for 10 minutes while the
unit undertakes a deep clean wow this is
some weird Robocop [ __ ] visitors will
have to pay to use the toilets laughs
what why would you have to pay to you
take a [ __ ]
Hey oh man if I was going to a place and
you had to pay to take a [ __ ]
guess what I'm doing [ __ ] outside of
it right there bro I'll [ __ ] close to
where you pay you think I won't [ __ ]
close to where you pay that's the real
[ __ ] for real you're gonna make me pay
to [ __ ] where's the doorway dude here we
go Beach what's he doing bro you're not
charging me to take dumps oh what's he
doing draw that guy's crazy what the
[ __ ] Oh is he [ __ ] outside the door
why because they were robbed oh because
they wanted me to pay for it
god damn he knows the rules doesn't he
goddamn he lives a sound life god damn
he's got a code like Dexter this is
coming out anyway you're not gonna make
me pay for it
however twitter users have questions how
the systems in particular the weight
sensitive floors will work in practice
one said oh just the fact that anyone
would tweet about this one said weight
sensitive floors to detect more than one
user what baseline weight are they using
I'm easily the weight of two teenagers
and what about people who need
assistance I have to go in with my kids
oh man
imagine you walk in with your two kids
that need to take a [ __ ] and all of a
sudden they [ __ ] douse you with water
an alarm goes off and the doors open and
then they think you're a pedophile by
the way oh you went in with kids he's
trying to [ __ ] kids what the [ __ ] you're
just an American in there I was on
vacation in Griffith Griffin Park I
don't know what's happening dude what
the [ __ ] is happening oh no oh yeah you
need to take a [ __ ] oh let's all go in
together cuz I don't I don't trust
anybody we all got to get in together
and this is a family and everything and
here we go for it oh no what the [ __ ] is
going on no wait what the [ __ ] ah c'mon
kids here we go
[Music]
another added there are obvious serious
questions about weight sensors with
potential for cruel humiliation of
facility users as a robot I am concerned
with one thing there are obvious serious
questions about weight sensors the
potential for accrual humiliation of
facility users
I would like to take a [ __ ]
I weigh in excess of 310 pounds
oh my circuitry No why would you listen
to this podcast dude there's NPR talking
about robots [ __ ] in Wales and
getting blasted the it's an escape from
reality dude that's like Mac to me ya
lamu wants the going grandma do you want
some going family look imagine e wants
the guns Ram but he's obviously gone
remedies the existing facilities are due
to close in October while the demolition
and construction of new built of the new
building takes place do it amazing so go
take a [ __ ] in Wales
are we doing two breaks okay expressvpn
hmmm internet privacy is basically dead
you can't even go to the bathroom
anymore with them opening the doors and
sounding the alarm in Wales but look at
porn for instance did you know that UK
the government in UK passed a law
requiring you to hand over your ID
before you can access porn sites um okay
that's right like your driver's license
or a passport um yeah okay it's only a
matter of time before your government
gets the same idea yeah no kidding hello
America and what happens when your
favorite porn site gets
like Ashley Madison did uh-oh all those
names and ID's will be floating around
waiting to get published on the web and
then you're screwed
that's why I protect my internet usage
with expressvpn accessing the internet
with expressvpn means the websites you
visit won't know where you're coming
from shielding your identity expressvpn
is the best way to make sure your online
activity is anonymous and it's the VPN
provider that I trust to protect my data
okay
numb Chris D'Elia for less than seven
dollars a month you can get the same
expressvpn protection that I have
because you probably like a public-house
forty thousand dollars no seven dollars
there's if you comes with a 30-day
money-back guarantee it's time to stop
Big Brother and surveillance of your
online activity protect yourself today
and find out how you can get three
months free at expressvpn comm /
Congrats that's expr ESS VPN dot-com /
congrats for three months free with a
one-year package visit Express VPN
dot-com / Congrats to learn more farmers
dawg
I use it for my doggies because I want
to keep them healthy and lean dog food
companies love using fancy recipe names
and colorful pictures of real meat and
veggies on their bag but it seems no
matter what the brand or the price or
the ingredients on the label all you'll
find inside are unidentified dried-out
unidentifiable dried-out brown nugs dude
and by that I mean nuggets why do we
accept this is food let alone as healthy
food for living beings as awesome as
dogs you ever seen a dog dude they're so
cute man why do you want to you want to
keep them healthy man what kind of beef
or carrot sits on the shelf for months
or years that's not what this farmer's
dog does the comedy that helps dogs live
longer healthier lives by making it easy
and convenient to feed them fresh food I
use it but dogs love it this scarf it up
man meals have pre-portioned easy to
serve packs and because they're
delivered by subscription you always
have food on hand
look clever marketing has convinced pet
owners to equate unhealthy and highly
processed kibble with food but unlike
kibble the farmers dog actually looks
and smells like real food because it's
real food that's why it's because it's
real food start feeding your dog better
today get 50
percent off your two-week trial of fresh
healthy food at the farmer dog the
farmers dog dot-com sash Congrats
plus you get free shipping what just go
to the farmers dog calm / congrats to
get 50% off your two week trial that's
the farmers dog calm / Congrats blast
they're killing it in Wales but up up by
yah the killing in Wales looking at my
phone because I'm being respectful to
you guys because I'm not disrespectful
because I'm being me and the most
respectful thing you can do is exactly
what you own at any given time
especially around other people because
you're gifting them you that's why my
mom thinks I'm I'm a jerk because I
didn't but I don't follow different
rules around and that's [ __ ] bad in
things like relationships not just with
the girl but with people but it's all
good dude we have a [ __ ] new zoomed
in look on the [ __ ] video and it's
[ __ ] awesome dude it's something I've
thought about for a little bit and now I
did it and it's cool man I look manly in
it how about that dude I'm flexing cuz
I'm respectful whoa dude is that a tree
trunk um anyway what else was I gonna
say I was gonna say something I don't
memo
I don't memo you guys do baby voice with
your significant others I don't know if
that's a good or bad thing I had one
girl I that's all I did it I we didn't
talk regular all we did was baby voice
and it was because we headed each other
we only liked the young versions of
ourselves ran right away - [ __ ] baby
town and we chilled
we were it feels good you know it's very
uh cute and sweet to do baby to talk
with someone but then there's one girl I
had that it was like yo you don't do
baby voice with me understand me and I
was like okay and we never did it once
and that was okay too but we were we
were grown adults you know I wanted to
talk about something I can't remember
what it is now um bro when I was in law
when I was in my early 20s I will go to
this place Bob's Big Boy they guy they
had really good burgers now almost I
probably went every night for the
[ __ ] hole for a year when I wasn't
really concerned about my health I was
like 22 still looked like a [ __ ] you
know they people be like what's going on
with is that one of the [ __ ] vote is
it a velociraptor just because the hell
my [ __ ] body looked not a good thing
um so and uh and I would and I would eat
burgers just all the time and I would go
to Bob's Big Boy and I would go and
there was this guy named [ __ ] what was
his name
mootai UTA I that was his name where was
he from Mars where's that name from you
got me baby never heard the name before
in my life had hair like a lego guy like
had hair like it was a [ __ ] Spartan
hat his hair had more hairs per capita
than Neil deGrasse Tyson billions and
billions of particles billions of
follicles in my hair in my head started
billions and billions of years ago and
he an atty where's it from
looked like he could be from for real
Mexico Hawaii or Japan where was he from
ooh Thai and so I really liked going to
Bob's Big Boy man I started to know
everybody there there was a waitress
named Denise there was a guy named Kevin
Kevin always look like an 80s action
movie star I liked Kevin a lot he be
like hey what's going on man and we just
challenged
you like you want the burger and I'm
like of course I'm here aren't I
but every time I got butai he would come
up and never said anything I swear to
God
but this skip that's what he would say
he'd come up he'd say skip and I'd say
okay um yeah I'll get the burger and
he'd write it down and I'd say thanks
and he'd say hey skip skip dude es CIB
and any time I would bring a new person
there I'd be like ah
who dies here watch he's gonna say a
skip and they'd be like what what the
[ __ ] is a skip I said you [ __ ] just
sit back and relax you come up this skip
what do you want oh I'll get the salad
this cube and one time one night I
realized what he was saying and I
remember thinking oh that's what he's
saying and a week later I forgot what I
realized it was and I have never been
able to [ __ ] remember it again and
I'm so [ __ ] pissed that I don't
remember what I figured out his skip was
I think about it every now and then you
never know when some [ __ ] like that's
gonna hit in life man write this [ __ ]
down scared but what the [ __ ] is ask a
boot I skip what could it mean it's cute
it's not it what maybe was trying to say
something it's good but it wasn't it
wasn't it wasn't that it's good it was a
skip dude I'd watch his [ __ ] mouth
I'd watch his mouth do the Eska and the
book at the end
never give a [ __ ] about me at all Denis
was sweet and and then I went back years
later and the [ __ ] I was like hey
how's Kevin been any [ __ ] I think he
died so what yeah he died sad man he was
just like a young guy who died still
there let me look up who died Bob's Big
Boy
Burbank Bob's Big Boy boy what have you
just had like [ __ ] 50,000 followers
on the Instagram it was [ __ ] a skip
on his [ __ ] his Instagram handle skip
and he's just like living that escaped
life and he's just like this just it
still don't know where he is cause he's
in the place he's just [ __ ] other
guys in Wales bathrooms and it's just
like oh no he just went on family oh no
[ __ ] skip he goes into the [ __ ]
thing oh no butch
oh no just [ __ ]
[Music]
blasted hair all wet but still puffy
because he's got so much hair all wet
but still puffy cuz he got so much about
jay-z [ __ ] did
yeah at Travis Scott shouldn't play in a
Super Bowl because they don't stand with
cap what the NFL wants me to be over see
what they doing with them with football
I sign it as long as I can make money
that's what people think he's doing I
don't know if that's what he's doing or
not but people are up in arms his bob's
big boy
I looked up who died who died images for
who died Bob's Big Boy you know
let's go to images nope
I can't believe I remember his name but
not if Kevin actually died look what the
[ __ ] is wrong with my brain that I
remember some guy saying ass Gib and his
[ __ ] name was dude I but I can't
actually remember if the guy I liked the
most there died what the [ __ ] dude dude
there was a TMZ thing that somebody
tweeted me it was like they were like uh
well this is funny or something and I
watched it bro I have zero recollection
of it I'm 39 I mean I'm not even close
to 40 dude I have a zero idea about a
TMZ guy coming up to me asking me about
some [ __ ] and then a homeless guy came
up to me and did it did a joke I don't
remember it could be a deep fake for all
I know all right I don't want to upgrade
the [ __ ] thing dude
Mac you know oh I got to do the second
dads I'll do it right now
my bookie it's a new season Antonio
Brown is on the Raiders LaVon Belle is
with the Jets Odell Beckham is in
Cleveland the one thing that hasn't
changed where I'm putting my money down
on all the games my bookie is the place
to bet on football every weekend my
bookie has better bonuses and more prop
bets than any other sports book period
this year they're hosting the first
online handicapping super contest first
place is guaranteed to win at least
$100,000 and it only cost $100 to enter
hum hello no-brainer are you there yeah
yeah right here all you got to do is
pick five NFL games against the spread
every week to climb the leaderboard and
score your share of the huge cash prize
pool that's why my bookie is always the
right play you bet you win they pay my
bookie has live in game betting on every
NFL game what more could you ask for
they've got the most rewarding player
perks in the business and for your
fantasy and for your fantasy guys out
there you can even bet the
under on how many fantasy points a
player will score each game there's a
lot of stuff you can bet on up to $1,000
first deposit bonus double your first
deposit use promo code Congrats
to activate the offer visit my bookie
online today that's my B oh okay ie and
don't forget to use the promo code
Congrats CO and gr 80s and when creating
your account to acclaim the bonuses the
bonus BET win get paid go love go they
really came up man they really did I've
used a bunch of these sneaker apps to do
it and goat is just the best Yeezys
Jordans off lights if you're going to
buy sneakers for a few hundred dollars
how can you make sure that the real
thing you don't want these fakes on your
feet man people will see it and then
realize it and then take a picture of it
and put online and laugh at you
goat comm is the safest way to end that
and the day it's the safest way to buy
and sell authentic sneakers online
they're the largest market place in the
world for authentic Easy's Jordans and
over 600,000 sneaker listings they've
made the whole process frictionless and
trustworthy
they only accept sellers with the best
reputation and they verify the sneakers
to ensure their authenticity everything
from the laces to the soles and in
between stitching all that they certify
every pair of sneakers over half a
million users on the platform come on
ten million use over weight with over
half a million sneakers on the platform
and 10 million users bro be one of those
you won't find better prices verified
100%
I thought you see use anywhere else find
the perfect 100% authentic sneaker at
go.com slash Congrats that's goat comm /
Congrats
plus you'll also be supporting our show
but you got to go right now before the
sneakers you want are gone when you go
to goat comm / Congrats spelled Geo 80
comm / Congrats cash app congratulations
is brought to you by the cash app the
official app of the log cannon yeah I'm
watching this are I'm listening to this
podcast called 22 hours because it was
recommended to me because it's about
true crime stuff it's about this house
that burned down and they found people
in it and they found that they found out
that
was a murder was a [ __ ] like
quadruple homicide or something was like
a kid there and like I'm so sad but for
five episodes it just seemed like okay
the guy did it why are we listening to
this podcast and then on the sixth
episode dude they changed the whole deal
I was like what I'm in but five minutes
in it's funny dude what it takes to with
the voice like the voices that they use
like the person that they use has so
much to do with it and the music has so
much to do with it like five minutes in
I was hooked on the first episode it was
just like a family was in the thing and
blah blah blah blah and I'm like
witnessing I know losing the thing my
god and the house was burned down and
and then they got the music beep beep
boop boop
okay one second a family sorry with the
families and and the thing and I'm just
on the plane and some fat guys next to
me using my armrest and all of a sudden
I don't care anymore
yeah he's using my armors but the family
was in the thing hold on a second yeah
man it's good it's called 22 hours I
guess check it out if you like that
stuff that true crime stuffs all the
rage man
people love listening to podcasts like
this you really wanna hit it back rewind
it you talked to me that's me when I'm
listening to a podcast and somebody says
something hold on rewind it you talked
to me I can't text and listen to podcast
too I don't know what the [ __ ] going
on immediately as soon as I pick up of
it says somebody text me you got a text
and I'm listening i text back i'm gonig
i start the whole podcast over that's
Adam I am
I did all right look this is what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna talk about this
because it's been in my notes for
literally five months it's called I
wrote down the deserve it scale all
right and one fire is always like what
the [ __ ] is the deserve it scale and
it's been on the notes and we laugh
because it's so dumb
the deserve it scale made about as much
sense to him as a skip all right the
deserve it scale is is I think we might
have maybe touched on this in a podcast
before but a video online of a guy
falling just a guy falling and he
doesn't deserve it is not as it can be
funny there's always exceptions but the
deserve it scale is what makes it funny
to me okay if a guy's twirling plates on
a [ __ ] basketball and falls down his
deserve it scale is off the charts and
I'm [ __ ] laughing harder because he's
a [ __ ] idiot you understand I know
he's gonna fall and he doesn't there was
a video of a kid on top of a fruit of a
cupboard this is a long time ago in on
America's Funniest Home Videos you know
back when the internet wasn't a thing
and this kid was on the top of the
cupboard and he was gonna scare he set
up the camera who's gonna scare his
family and it was just gonna be great
right set up the whole thing the kid
goes rawr and slips his pants catch on
the top of the cupboard and he falls
down and his ass crack is facing the
camera now that deserve it scale is off
the charts
because he set it all up stood on the
cupboard and waited for his dad so it
was so what funny dude here's another
good one man one time there's a guy
skiing down a mountain bro I lost my
[ __ ] at this okay
and he was skiing down the mountain and
the guy was at the bottom of the [ __ ]
slow filming it it was like a you know
like so I'm so far away the guy was just
Shh she's doing the [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] that skiers do shh shh you're a
super [ __ ] of your skiing you know and
he gets close to the guy with the camera
and the guy with the camera you can just
sense you know there was just like a
sense that he had where he was like
uh-oh some shits about to go down and
the guy go
the guy skiing says oh sorry Chris and
then smashes into the guy with the
camera oh because he said sorry before I
pissed bro if you know you're gonna [ __ ]
up can't stop and apologize beforehand
the desert scales so high first of all
don't even [ __ ] shoot it just let the
guy live life the best deserve it scale
though I ever saw was at a wedding this
was a Funniest Home Videos I've looked
this video up forever online there was a
wedding going on and the I guess it was
the groom that on the indoors wedding
you know gymnasium or wherever the [ __ ]
this thing was he gets on the motorcycle
that was there for some reason
okay now the deserve it scale dude is
that Mach 10 all right this guy's on it
first of all motorcycle in a gymnasium
that's not it at a wedding that's not it
at his wedding all right the deserve it
scale I mean if there was a weight
sensor it would be
oh okay now this guy revs it and he is
just he seems dope as [ __ ] okay cuz he
had on I remember he had on like uh uh
not a traditional thing he hadn't like a
cool thing because he wanted to look
cool on the motorcycle thing and and he
went to take off and you go to and
obviously didn't know how to ride a
motorcycle that well because he didn't
let go of the handle and the [ __ ]
motorcycle kept going and he was doing
like the rule and he tried to stand up
off of it because it got too and the
motorcycle went into all the decorations
and took out all the decorations and
ruined the wedding dude and I cried the
desert scale was [ __ ] Mach 10 and I
think that's when I created the desert
scale when I was a kid anyway what I
want you to do because I love deserve at
scale videos send your favorite deserve
it scale videos okay now you know
there's different levels like the skiing
one wasn't so high but the motorcycle at
the wedding one was just off the charts
right you ever see the grape smash one
where the girls like okay and go and
they're on a level up and they're
smashing the grapes and it's a [ __ ]
you know middle-aged woman that's like
portly and she's like go go go go go go
go and then she falls off of the [ __ ]
level thing and then he's like remember
that video did you ever see a fire at
one fire you seen it
oh man let's watch that one that one is
such a high deserve at scale oh man when
I would watch this on Ebaum's world when
I was [ __ ] 12 smashing fail she's so
out of breath great lady Falls original
so sad to be the great lady what kind of
great these are filled with chamber sin
grapes and the winner this Saturday is
stop music
best thing is they both they both have
[ __ ] zero clue that this shit's about
to go down and my favorite thing about
it is I know it's gonna go down that's
the best because otherwise why would it
even be on the internet when dude I used
to love America's own videos because
they would [ __ ] show the video and
you knew you were smarter than the
[ __ ] idiot on the veteran camera you
knew some [ __ ] was gonna go down and
they had no idea and I would just sit
there giddy with Anik looking oh I can't
wait for this guy to fall and they would
fall and I would the [ __ ] would just be
an uber sensation you're they are here
they're there on a [ __ ] platform
that's like I mean it's like three and a
half feet up what a bad [ __ ] idea
dude and why are they wearing the same
thing because they work for the place
and it's a sad the whole thing here we
go oh I remember what happens to before
we've been watching she stops and they
like okay stop and then this is what
made it extra funny she was like wait a
little bit more and that's when she
falls it's a lot of fun
[Music]
oh-oh-oh-oh
yeah buddy
what makes you say that you [ __ ]
regular guy and the winner this Saturday
international music okay she says stop
now she's even though it's a joke it's
it's what she gets it's what she gets
man I'm sorry lady
but you're on a [ __ ] four foot
platform up that is so small it could be
an elevator it's the size of an elevator
and then you're stomping slippery gray
and then you don't stop after you say
stop and even as a joke that's not the
rules lady you said stop
you said it by the way and then she goes
she goes a little bit more like a
[ __ ] bro we've all been there she
can't not breathe out because it hit and
she can't not breathe out she's in so
much pain that she just lets a little
bit of sound out and it just turns in it
she can't think of breath in bro that's
so funny I feel bad but she's probably
okay that's the bit you know does the
other thing too if you know they've done
some permanent damage and it's not funny
anymore cuz you feel bad but I think
this lady's okay she's at the top she's
at the top level of I think she's okay
if she went any further then it's not
okay like those skateboarding videos
where people fall down and break their
femurs I'm not into that this [ __ ] here
she's saying stop she doesn't realize
what she's saying because there's
nothing to be stopped that's the bet
that's also very funny because she's
just saying stop because she's like
praying to the gods that this should
stop but you can't
No look at these guys I think she's
actually hurt no I think she is hurt she
took a hard fall off there
well hey gosh I hope she's okay okay
we're gonna make sure she yes right
check on her and get back as soon as we
can we'll be back right after this
oh man okay let's read about her here
the go up yeah so okay okay oh wow
there's a whole story here Oh okay
Melissa Sanders was a reporter for an
Atlanta TV station in the late 90s doing
a fluff report from a local winery she
participated in an impromptu grape
stomping contest when disaster
hilariously struck memo to parents if
this is what I was saying if you really
want to show your kids that cheaters
never prosper you might want to consider
using this video as visual aid exactly
even though it was a [ __ ] light
competition you stop when you say stop
after being told that time was up
stander kept by though it was her that
said the time was up I mean look at the
way this is written sander kept stomping
and was quickly bitch-slapped by the
hand of fate tumbling over the side you
know her wall bursts like screams while
obviously I mean - who wrote this well
obviously amusing her - her co-workers
in the studio know they were sad seem to
indicate a serious injury there's
somebody in the comments section
claiming sander broke several ribs and
almost died oh come on they think it's
funny or that way they're saying push it
go back up she was fine said she was
fine click on that oh wait hold on and
by the way was basically her fault
because they chose to film facing the
side yeah really without railings click
on that know that oh you got it okay go
back yeah go tree down
Honore down according to bloggers who
have tried to track her down shortly
after the incident sander left Atlanta
for Albany which we're sure had nothing
to do with the fact that the Institute's
were barely holding back giggles and her
pain yodeling our bio page is a bio page
in Albany makes no but no mention of a
near-death experience due to pierce too
long a Pierson
which further supports the I mean what
the [ __ ] is this you know if people will
just be like think anything's a
conspiracy she's no longer the jaw
dropped off the face of the earth let's
try to find her you know go up go up
click her bio page right there oh there
it is he's probably not up anymore right
yeah it's not there anymore well we wish
her all the best here at congratulations
you know um but the desert scale was
mighty high on that one wasn't quite as
big as the [ __ ] motorcycle in them
but man no railings if I was working
there and that happened while she was
falling I'd be like I mean we knew it
yeah you want to do some questions okay
it's got some questions Oh a grumble oh
well hmm a lot of people don't know
what's a [ __ ] means but this is a good
one page at legs for days
I guess change it probably cuz that's
you know how [ __ ] is it to be the first
person scooting in a corner booth at a
restaurant yeah yeah because you got to
be like use your [ __ ] palms and scoot
yeah it's pretty [ __ ] boot [ __ ] boot
it's pretty [ __ ] it's pretty boot it's
pretty [ __ ] especially if you're like a
[ __ ] white guy that is wearing shorts
you're a [ __ ] major [ __ ] if you do
that white guys have the most submit
[ __ ] what do you call it what's the
what's the word it's a very easy word
where you can what's the word where you
can wow I came to think of how to
describe this word but it's a very easy
word hold on a guy second babies have to
come through oh Jesus Christ what a
brain [ __ ] hold on it this does not
happen in a long time
potential Jesus
Jesus they have the most high so [ __ ]
potential white guys with shorts and
blonde hair for sure okay let's go to
another one
Chris D'Elia would you rather okay
Megalodon at Megan underscore Sullivan
would you rather ride in this car or fly
United she knows I hate United because
me United [ __ ] sucks they're run by
cats this is a [ __ ] oh my we'll put
the picture up I mean dude this truck
first of all its neon green with [ __ ]
what are those snake eyes on the back
that are the blinkers no it's not
spider-man but they do have Ghost Rider
on the back [ __ ] window and just
these decals on it
love is lame on the top K so deeper
holla for $1 choke hard just like okay
well an unnecessarily oh my god dude
there's the Hello Kitty thing and
instead of the eyes it has boobs and it
says hello titty hey guy you're a man
because you have your license what are
you doing I like girls that drink beer
ester ASIS are rapists my other ride is
my sexy girlfriend as a sexist I like to
spoon but I love to fork I mean dude you
don't you know might as well put [ __ ]
right cuz you already put oh my god dude
ass the other vagina oh my god dude it
says real women swallow bro imagine
driving around in this Isle of vag
boobies we stare because we care
Oh foreskin holds germs just for why to
get medical oh my god dude I hate smelly
vag just on the back of his car
oh and the license plate is a meat wagon
meet WGN Pennsylvania real men don't buy
girls i see the short bus is missing a
passenger I mean this whole thing is the
most offensive back of a car ever Uranus
is huge okay not so not funny just so
not funny to do the planet thing with
the [ __ ] making it like it's an
[ __ ] and then on the upper left of
the [ __ ] back truck back of the truck
it says protected by acid spitting
kittens for no reason no it's not and
his ghostwriter on the back you know
just like so offensive and then just
ghostwriter
hello titty you know oh my god I like to
snack I've never heard how bad I like to
snatch kisses and vice versa
one thing you know about this guy is
that he's white I mean any Asian or
black or any Asian guys would look at
this car be like this and black guys
would look at cart the car like this
they would have the like that like that
meme of the they'd be like damn they'd
have that look and Persian guys would
watch this car and be like this oh oh
what you don't know I mean the only
person that would be like oh that's
pretty funny it would be like a white
guy you know oh damn oh hey hey and they
would call Persians would be like a
check this fool out look at this what
the [ __ ] bro
a Nima what or a mirror look what the
[ __ ] bro it says I like I like
girls that drink beer dog you can oh
[ __ ]
imagine you're driving behind this guy
and you see watch out the idiot behind
me decal on there you're bussing him up
or what damn dude Ghost Rider that kills
me that Ghost Rider's on it
what nut nice fart can like a but nice
fart can it says wow this guy is for
sure white and definitely has a beard
there's no way this guy's like a
clean-cut guy well I love thinking about
a Persian guy looking at this car oh
yeah how much would you pay how much how
much would you would I have to pay you
to drive around in that that's what a
perfect guy would say all right next one
I get would you ride in this car or fly
United I mean hey fly United but never
be in that car dude
oh here's a good one Roberto Rob Herrera
jr. lol why do you always well he meant
as they say what he didn't left out a
word cuz he's [ __ ] writing too fast
got really excited why do you always say
my opener instead of their actual name
because because that's what they deserve
dude he's got the best job in comedy man
he goes out there does some [ __ ] makes
[ __ ] thousands of dollars selling his
merch and he [ __ ] I also don't always
say it but it cuz it's funny it's a joke
because sway deserves and then after
that he did a follow-up tweet that says
say Christ yeah so that's it that's what
I do that's why I do that and that's
what I do and that's it that's it for
the episode of my babies thank you very
much
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play market and you
could also so don't forget to do that
it's better than all the other apps then
all the other apps that you send money
on also do the get my app get my app
either at the App Store and you can
download the crystal the crystal II app
just by renting Cresselia and where we
get apps support the show by buying
merch at store Chris Leo calm we've got
a big
stock restock coming soon and we love we
love the support and rate and review the
show on iTunes that really helps us and
subscribe to the YouTube channel the
YouTube show comes up day after the
regular one does on the audio so that
shows in San Jose other than all sold
out its conch which ones aren't
San Diego Fox when I seen the one did I
had another one I think
Foxwoods Connecticut Detroit Detroit new
data added there's a few tickets left
for my taping in Minneapolis I think we
got to there
Tampa Detroit you did at it yeah Houston
knew they'd added El Paso you guys Rock
thank you very much and that's it see
you babe
[Music]